en force chez reed de la famille
trintignant mari avait commencé à faire
ses premiers pas devant la caméra dès
l'enfance une personnalité au charme
énigmatique est la voix sombre est
immédiatement reconnaissable
une actrice et une comédienne accomplie
une femme de passion et de tumulte
jacques chirac en ce soir hommage à
celle qui servait son art avec beauté
sensibilité intelligence marianne
bonhomme rémy posséder pour son dernier
rôle celui de colette marie trintignant
à travailler en famille avec sa mère
réalisatrice son fils comédien et son
frère assistant réalisateur
le clan trintignant et surtout son père
jean-louis avec qui elle avait des liens
si forts
je crois que petite elle n'a jamais
pleuré je sais pas je ne me souviens pas
que qu'elle ait été un moment un
problème souci elle a été que du bonheur
deux pièces de théâtre ensemble poèmes à
lou et conversations sur un quai de gare
michel je m'appelle michel c'est marrant
comme ça dure et que sa mort
à 4 ans elle voulait être vétérinaire
mais sa mère lui confier un rôle dans
mon amour mon amour
marie trintignant a tourné une trentaine
de films elle s'impose en 1992 dans
betty de claude chabrol dans le cri de
l'asseoir 1996 sa beauté et son talent
éclate elle a voulu être comédienne pour
soigner sa timidité
ça aide parce que c'est le cinéma la
télévision c'était pour elle le même
métier
en 99 et les victoires qui luttent pour
l'avortement c'est que les avortements
clandestins
l'utilisation des sons des aiguilles à
tricoter diverses plantes et un réel
danger pour les femmes
l'an dernier le chanteur thomas fersen
lui avait écrit une chanson marie cette
bosse très singulière qui qui m'a plu et
puis je sentais que je pouvais écrire
des histoires et surtout elle pouvait
incarner des personnages que je pouvais
d'écrire dans mes chansons
marie trintignant un destin brisé
à 41 ans